welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host death bei there and this is
the channel where we break down all the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books with the rise of
skywalker about a hit cinemas worldwide
next week we actually have a new full
pop breakdown that broke the internet
last night from someone who has
apparently seen the entire movie episode
9 has been plagued with reshoots script
leaks and a number of changes to its
plot but it looks like we finally know
what's going to be in the release of the
film that will be making its way to
cinemas next week throughout this video
we're going to be going through the
entire plot as leaked by The Insider and
discussing all of the ins and outs of
the story there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you want to go into the movie
fully closed off from the force then I
highly suggest that you turn off now I
know you know you want to ruin it for
yourself don't you I can feel the hate
flowing to you search your feelings talk
without it's terrible as with all leaks
we won't know if these are for definite
until we see the final film for
ourselves but they do line up a lot with
the leaks behind the scene images and
things that have made their way to the
internet in the past still take it with
a pinch of salt as it could be untrue
anyway with all that out the way thank
you for clicking the video now let's get
into our full plot breakdown of the rise
of Skywalker okay so this leak comes
from reddit user Jedi paksas who claims
to have an inside source that has seen
the entire film the user says that they
vetted them and the redditor has
actually posted a number of leaks in the
past that turned out to be true before
we ever saw them in trailers such as
c-3po red eyes and the return of the
Emperor I'm just going to be reading
this plot leaked with a couple of
changes to what pax is put just to keep
it tighter for the video but I'll leave
a link in the description below if you
want to go through the entire thing
yourself okay so the insider said that
the film begins with kylo slaughter of
natives in the red light woods to get to
bait his wayfinder the wayfinder is a
pyramid shaped object that hooks up to
kylos TIE fighter to allow him to see
how to get 2x a goal kylo flies to a red
nebula like section of space to get
there as was seen in recent TV spots for
the movie
once annex egala kylo apparently wanders
into what looks like a science lab and
Palpatine's voice can be heard claiming
that he made Snoke and that he's been
orchestrating everything from the
shadows this lines up a lot with leaks
that would drop last week with snug
apparently being revealed to be a clone
and kylo discovers copies of him on X
goal with regards to Palpatine's initial
appearances flashes of lightning reveal
his face but he has completely white
eyes and his body is attached to a
vertical metal arm that leads somewhere
we don't see Palpatine apparently
discusses his large Armada and orders
kylo to locate Rey which he takes as to
kill her Palpatine warns him no she's
not what you think the film then cuts to
an ice asteroid base sequence which is
when we see Poe Finn and Chewie on the
Falcon and they're all playing hollow
chess two-on-one they insinuate Chewie
cheats and he gets a bit annoyed about
it but Poe makes a comment about how
it's obvious that he's better than them
because he's so much older
Chewie gets up to check something and
they light him saying that they won't
turn off the game because they're losing
but they do this when his backs turned
anyway they're here to meet a
first-order informant known as Bulli
who is acting as a middleman between a
first-order mole and our heroes the
contact tosses them as satchel with all
of the background information in it and
Poe and Finn pry the contact to get the
molds name but he won't budge the first
order then arrives and begins attacking
the base and the assault forces our
heroes to make a hasty exit by what is
described to be as Lightspeed skipping
we learn that a Lightspeed skip involves
their making a jump to light speed
without plotting a course or a
predetermined destination as we all
remember making the jump to light speed
without precise calculations can have
dire consequences such as flying through
a star or bouncing too close to a
supernova and the Falcon makes a handful
of these skips to throw the first order
off their trail as a result though
they're forced to deal with the
consequences of such a risky maneuver
and the Falcon sets on fire because of
it - and Poe reconnect when the Falcon
lands at the resistance jungle base and
we see members of the resistance running
to put the fire out that we can see
coming from the Falcon this is where
they dropped the line about the damage
being incurred because of Lightspeed
skipping and this makes ray very upset
with Poe during Rey's training on the
jungle base she gets very frustrated and
tosses her lightsaber
by carelessly causing trees to fall and
want to damage bb-8 anyway the
resistance reviews the information
gained from the data encoder and they
find out about the Sith fleet and
Palpatine's returned the combined forces
of Palpatine in the first order are
apparently called the final order and we
learned that Luke was searching for EXO
goal but was unable to obtain a
Wayfinder to get there which sought
becomes the big MacGuffin of the movie
the source says that rose is little more
than a background character and that she
has some lines throughout but nothing
too significant largely just
motivational things like let's get them
and make Star Wars great again I'm
kidding
she didn't say that anyway layer decides
that they need to end this threat once
and for all and a team is formed before
taking off a few new things who
apparently added in the reshoots
including a scene in which layer gives
right her lightsaber back and mass gives
Rey a little pep talk before she leaves
ray tells the crew that Luke left behind
some notes and coordinates within the
Jedi texts she stole from the tree
library on a cue that describes a Sith
artifact that might help them the source
instead they go to persona to seek out a
hermit that Luke knew they arrive on the
planet and find a huge festival that's
going on there and attempt to meet the
contact what they thought would be an
easy mission has now turned into a much
more complex one and they try and lay
low and blend in unsurprisingly though
Chewbacca struggles with this because
yeah it's very difficult to hide a
seven-foot-tall wookie and Rey
encounters an alien in the crowd who
takes a liking to her this alien
presents her with a handmade necklace
and a gift and she's asked her name to
which she responds Rey when asked her
family name she replies that she doesn't
have one which remember that yeah cuz it
plays into the end so remember that I'm
telling you following this there's a
meeting where kylo discusses the first
sort of spy to a room of offices and he
immediately says hugs his name but
seemingly changes the subject the source
also says that this meeting is the first
time that we see pride and during the
movie he mentions serving Palpatine
during the days of the empire after the
meeting kylo and Rafe all spawned on
persona he follows her through the crowd
taunting her that she doesn't have a
family as soon as she snaps out of it
Rey draws the attention of some
stormtroopers who immediately recognized
them
but they're swiftly handled by locals
while a hero team is whisked away by
someone who's eventually revealed to be
Lando greetings and introductions are
exchanged and Lando tells them of a
dagger that may help them find what they
seek many as prior Lando and Luke went
and searched of this dagger that was
owned by a Syd lawless named Archie they
tracked Archie to persona but
unfortunately the trail went cold
when met with the question of why he
never left the planet after the search
for Archie Lando tells the team that he
had a young child at the time of this
and while they were out searching for
the dagger the first order stole them
after having failed to protect his child
from the first order Lando and Luke
parted ways and he stayed on persona
ever since Lando points them in the
right direction and this starts off a
speeder chase when the last trooper is
finally dispatched he hits the hero
speeder which ends up flinging them into
quicksand
in this scene Finn shouts at Ray
thinking they're gonna die that he has
something to tell her but they all get
sucked down too quickly when the team is
sucked beneath the sand Poe asks Finn
and Rey if they're okay - which Threepio
apparently comments I didn't hear you
mentioned my name sir but I'm also fine
no terrible impression again down in the
tunnels poll asks Finn what he was going
to say to Rey in front of everyone but
Finn brushes it off saying that they can
talk about it later while looking for an
exit they encounter the sand worm that's
been previously mentioned in other leaks
and the source says that it looks a lot
like a Viper
which is quite intimidating however they
go on to say that there's no battle with
a snake it's just a scene of Rey
sneaking up to it noticing a wound and
then she uses a lifeforce to heal it it
slithers away revealing Archie ship
which they then stumble across do is
found an Archie ship and he is evidently
extremely timid apparently he belonged
to Archie and was abused very bad and he
only speaks when spoken to you and tends
to shy away from people on the ship they
also discover that Archie wasn't just a
loyalist he was actually a Sith assassin
and they find his dagger which as part
of their tradition has information
inscribed on it according to the leaks
c-3po can read it he knows what it says
and he tells the resistance crew that it
reveals the location of the Wi-Fi
but its programming forbids him from
providing a literal translation of the
text the leaks say that Chewbacca is
then captured here after he wanders off
to get Rey and two troopers happen upon
him after a little while often goes to
locate Chewie and seize him in cuffs
boarding a transport and he runs to
report this to Poe this is meant to be
when the big fight with Ray and the TIE
fighter happens which ends with ray
slicing kylo swing off during the flip
and he crashes whilst all this is
transpiring the Poe Finn Threepio BBA
and so on get Archie ship in the air
just in time to fly over to pick up a
very distraught ray Chewbacca had the
knife with him and having been caught
this is now in the hands of kylo and Coe
however luckily for them Threepio has
committed it to memory
I'm told that we have a quick cut at
this point back to kylo which is where
we find out that the Knights of Ren have
tracked the resistance team to kid Jimmy
it's kid Jimmy it might be cagey me I
don't know it's written really weirdly
anyway the resistance team arrives on
the planet and bump into Zuri bliss and
her crew she comes from Poe's past and
reveals that he once functioned as a
spice runner and that he still owes her
money quick skirmish occurs where ray
gets the upper hand and Zuri agrees to
bring them to baba frick we learned that
if Threepio is reset and he can read the
dagger but it means a complete wiping of
his memory banks still reeling from the
loss of Chewbacca the heroes argue about
finding another way to get the job done
but in an act of self-sacrifice
c-3po voluntarily consents to the
modifications according to the source
this scene is reportedly one of the most
emotional in the entire film and Frick
completes the hack and Threepio is now
able to read the message inscribed on
the dagger this is what creates the
repeals red eyes and the translated text
points them to the location of the
Emperor's own wayfinder having served
his purpose three POS memory-wipe begins
and he shuts down once the memory wipe
is complete Threepio reboots with a
completely empty memory during the hack
scene Threepio apparently takes shots at
r2d2 when they mentioned his memory wipe
could be restored by him as Threepio has
zero confidence in him Zuri and Poe
reminisce and she tries to get him to
leave with her buddy refuses and they're
then assaulted by first-order troops
kylo initiates another force bond with
ray and on his Star Destroyer
Rey manages to grab the dagger she sees
Archie attacking her parents and they
apparently left her on jakku ran away
and are later killed in what appears to
be a city setting this was all because
they wouldn't reveal the Archie where
Rey actually was as they were protecting
her at the end of the film it's actually
revealed that Archie was not sent to
kill ray but rather to retrieve her on
the Star Destroyer Hux is revealed to be
the spy and he rescues the heroes
telling Poe to shoot him in the arm but
instead of Poe shoots him in the leg
when asked why he's helping them Hux
replies that he doesn't care the first
order wins
he just won Scylla to lose he's killed
by pride when he reports the incident as
it's just so obvious what actually
happened
general pride is now the sole commander
of the first order military and the
emperor contacts him and demands that he
uses one of the specially equipped star
destroyers to destroy Keiji me as an act
of loyalty and pride complies the
information gained from three POS
translation of the dagger leads them to
the location of the second wayfinder
which turns out to be aboard the
wreckage of the second Death Star on the
forest moon of Endor along their way to
the wreckage the crew comes into contact
with a person named Janna who is
revealed to be land hos child Janna
provides Rey with transportation to get
to the Death Star wreckage and Rey
climbs through it's twisted remains the
source that leaked this information said
that the scene feels very reminiscent of
the activities that we saw ray doing in
the force awakens and she eventually
reaches the emperor's throne room and
discovers a chamber connecting to that
room that contains the second wayfinder
upon touching the wayfinder Rey then
interacts with a dark version of herself
the to fight and dark ray uses a folding
lightsaber to trap real Ray's on blade
easily gaining the upper hand and
driving home the point of just how much
more powerful she could be if she
submitted to the darkness after this she
snaps back to reality and the source was
under the impression that this may have
been due to Leia they claimed that right
after that moment we skipped to a
weakened being being led out of a
command room and someone comments that
it will take everything she has left to
reach her son the vision shocks ray and
she stumbles back into the throne room
where kylo is waiting for her kylo takes
possession of the emperor's wayfinder
destroys it and indicates to Rey that
the only way to get another way
find there is to go through him and take
Vader's lightsaber battle ensues
beginning in the throne room and
eventually transitioning to the exterior
wreckage among the crashing waves during
kylo and raised you on the Death Star
wreckage Rey is angry fighting him we
see her even force push Finn and Jan out
of the zone off in another part of the
galaxy while sky low and Rey clash
sabers bright light in the universe
begins to fade and Princess Leia dies
the source said that Leia's final words
are Ben which catches kylos attention
and is what distracts him long enough
for writers stabbing through the abdomen
and subsequently heal him during that
she takes his wayfinder and this kind of
plays into the finale
I'm told that Palpatine senses layers
there too making him more confident that
Rey now has nobody to turn to but him
sometime around here Palpatine orders kg
me to be destroyed as the first ships of
the Sith fleet reach the deployment
altitude during this battle Rey's also
apparently revealed to be the descendant
of Palpatine as well which completely
destroys her after kylo was stabbed han
shows up out of nowhere according to the
sauce he's not a force ghost it's as if
he's standing there alive again he gives
kylo some words of encouragement and
then their conversation very closely
mirrors Hans death scene in the force
awakens including their I know what I
have to do but I don't know if I have
the strength to do a bit he even holds
the lightsaber in the same spot but he
turns and throws it into the watery
wreckage of the Death Star Rey escapes
and manages to get away following her
experience there and she returns to the
island of act 2 is a achoo bless me
bless you throughout the course of the
film she's given into her aggression
nearly killed her friend by unleashing a
stream of lightning on a ship learned
that she's the descendant of a Sith Lord
who reduced the Jedi numbers to about
zero and saw a vision of herself as a
servant of the darkside and stabbed her
enemy through the chest in anger her
most recent encounter with kylo was the
last straw and right has now made the
decision to follow the example set by
Luke and exile herself on an island
where the Jedi began Rey skulls the ship
that she stole from kylo and throws the
repaired lightsaber originally
constructed by Anakin Skywalker in with
it the ghost of Luke Skywalker then
appears to Rey holding the weapon she's
just discarded Luke's conversation with
Rey is said to be encouraging yet
realistically grim in tone Luke knows
firsthand what it's like to face
Palpatine and that's not an easy task
raimus therefore confront Palpatine in
the same way that Luke had to confront
Vader Luke encourages Rey by telling her
of the faith that he and Leia have in
her lair saw the potential within her
and to hope that Ray would be able to
restore balance to the force
just like Anakin had this confirms that
both Luke and Leia know raisa Palpatine
yet chose to train her anyway when Rey
reaches at you and bless you she
actually does transmit the path the
hexagon to the resistance and there's
some initial confusion as they're
receiving a transmission from Red five
because she leaves in Luke's old x-wing
the resistance doesn't have sufficient
data to get there but apparently Finn
discovers that do knows the way Lando
leaves in the Falcon to get more forces
and the rest of the resistance mobilizes
with their newfound data and head up to
Ray right after his memory restoration
Threepio exclaims excitedly that he's
about to go on a mission but r2 tells
him it already happened much to Threepio
s confusion when Ray gets to X ecology
one is in meeting zero resistance and
happens upon the sit throne
Palpatine emerges on the mechanical arm
from one side revealing everything to
her including that the assassin was
meant to retrieve her never to kill her
they get surrounded by hundreds if not
thousands of Palpatine's acolytes while
Palpatine tries to go right to killing
him he also points to the fleet claiming
that she could become Empress Palpatine
do not tell the get whoa coal bro crowd
please to keep that quiet do not tell
him about Empress Palpatine Pete you're
gonna kick off in the comments anyway
kylo now Ben and his ex goal and get his
ass handed him by the Knights of Ren
just as Rey is about to strike at
Palpatine she initiates a force bond and
gives him lay his lightsaber Palpatine
apparently speaks about the bond that
they share and how extremely powerful
and rare it is for it to occur he then
sucks their life force to restore his
and we see his white eyes turn to the
yellow orange sit style the members of
the resistance arrive and begin fighting
the Sith fleet Palpatine and sees the
arrival of reinforcements and begins to
laugh throw
lightning into the air shutting down a
lot of ships including pose Palpatine
and throws run into a ravine and
claiming that he is the last Skywalker
in the line Rey then hears voices such
as Yoda Luke Leia mace windu and others
who give her the strength to stand up
Palpatine tries to lightening her but
she blocks it with one of her sabers and
seemingly stalemates them she then finds
the strength to pull the other saber up
making an X formation and this allows
her to deflect the lightning back
towards him
Palpatine apparently disintegrates and
explodes causing the arena to crumble
but also killing Rey in the process man
apparently claims out of the pit finding
a dead Rey and decides to give up his
life for hers he uses the healing trick
to save her but this drains his life
force in the process then apparently
there's a weird fanfic moment where they
kiss and he dies now this scene is
really weird as I did actually see a lot
of leaked images where ren was on the
planet at the end of the movie so yeah
it looks like they just went back and we
shot all that anyway we'll talk about it
in a bit Lando goes back for Jenna and
Finn who are on the Star Destroyer which
is falling out the air the fleet is
destroyed Rey survives and it looks like
the galaxy is saved this leads you to
see Chewie who he has mask all to him
and you think that she's gonna ask for a
kiss but instead she says you deserve
this and hands him a large medal they
did it the finally did it I'm crying
money do it
the movie ends with Rey going to Luke's
old moisture farm and Tatooine with his
and Leia's lightsabers to bury them she
now has a black and gray handle
lightsaber which she ignites a show a
yellow blade she and bebe are the only
ones present until a woman appears
asking her name to which she says Rey
Rey who then seeing Luke and Leia's
ghost in the distance she replies Rey
Skywalker as she clearly sees them as
the parents she was never able to have
rey and bebe look off at the set and
twin sons and the movie ends so there
you have it that's apparently the entire
plot of the rise of Skywalker and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it as mentioned earlier there was
actually a leaked image that showed ren
on Tatooine at the end so it sounds like
they've definitely we shot this as i've
seen it with my own eyes i just computed
in this video because disney
very strange either way but yeah comment
below and let me know and if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the scene that discusses
where Snoke really came from if you want
to come chat to me after the video then
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which would be linked in
the description below
we drop videos on there early so if you
want to see stuff before anyone else and
that's the best place to be it's free to
join and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 party box on blu-ray
which contains Black Panther infinity
war and Game Captain Marvel amour and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
'shy subscribe to the channel and leave
your thoughts on the leaks in the
comment section below the one it's gonna
be chose to on the 15th of December and
the set will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised it's the best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]